[Music]
hey
no
conclusion session 11 17 pm a testimony
of neander wallace to the magistrate's
sectors
el1r9 through 26 and so forth ended
empty
[Music]
thank you
for your patience
i did not intend to keep you waiting
the particulars of my affliction
make travel difficult
mr wallace we've granted you this
meeting in deference to your
contributions your essential
contribution
we recognize that for the public good
for their health
you remember hunger
so you indulge the reckless whose
patents keep that hunger at bay
i believe in life
in fact i have rung more life from our
earth than ever before
but it is dying you
are dying
which brings us to
our present concern
prohibition
we have made clear
our position the prohibition of
replicant technology is not subject to
debate
no
is its repeal
and yet we are debating
that we
of all that was lost in the blackout
this cut of history died on mourn
humanity has only survived this long by
crushing the earth to suit its needs
the stars
our only hope are hidden beyond the
lives you will not allow me to create
off well colonies are thriving
insufficient to the needs of ultimate
survival your laws have changed the
hands of progress the laws keep blood
off the streets
nexus phase is unreliable safeguards put
in place by tyrell with negligence too
many have died we will not add to that
number
my replicants
will live as long or as short as a
customer will pay
my replicants will never rebel
they will never run
they will simply obey
step forward
find a weapon do this now
what is this
this
is an angel
and i made him
look up to the left reveal
you're committing a crime wallace
now that's enough
lift the glass
god
no no no no no
this is wrong
does it hurt
[Music]
yes
you must make a choice
your life or mine
do you understand
yes
do this now
this is wrong
human action
resounds in the heavens
the bell echoes above
what we decide here today
[Music]
we'll polish or crack the firmament
[Music]
what shall it be
[Music]
i thought you might be able to help me
with the case
[Music]
any idea where i could find it
you police
plan on taking me here
i would much prefer that the alternative
every leap of civilization
was built off the back of slaves
replicants are the future but i can only
make so many
i had the luck and he has the key
i think you found him
that's not possible
if this gets out
we've bought ourselves a war
[Music]
you're a cop not at your job once
things were simpler than
what do you want
i want to ask you some questions
what happened
i covered my tracks and scramble the
records
we were being hunted
[Music]
by who
i know you're here
you do not know what pain is yet
you will learn
[Music]
bring it to me
this breaks the world
[Music]
we have to go i'm coming with you
where is he
the future of the species
is finally unearthed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you